you've probably seen this image before
maybe it appeared in your feed or maybe
you've seen it graffitied on a wall or
painted on a t-shirt so what do those
red and blue stripes really mean the
graph was created by Ed Hawkins a
British scientist in 2018 he was invited
to give a speech about climate change
and wanted to convey the increase in
global average temperatures to the
audience in a way that was both simple
to understand and striking so he devised
a chart that used no word just colors
it's known as the warming stripes and
uses blues for cooler than average years
and reds for hotter than average years
it goes all the way back to 1850 Hawkins
has been updating his graph every year
he says that
2022 was the very first year in which
every country needed a new red stripe
which shows just how fast the earth's
climate is
changing